bienvenue en irlande il était une fois
deux fermes voisines
la ferme des baux 12 mari vivait est au
bout du chemin il y avait ma ferme mon
fils anthony poser ces questions
solitaire aux étoiles pourquoi m'as-tu
fait ainsi rose-marie monde donne était
éperdument amoureuse il ya ces champs
verdoyants sur cette terre viennent un
peu importe que c'est ça me retient ici
quand il dit des choses comme celles là
mais pas dans patiemment moque tu
ressembles à john kerry
il était aussi timbre et la pleine lune
s'est noyé volontairement enlevé tomber
j'avais une roche attachée autour du cou
rose-marie on se connaît depuis assez
longtemps maintenant voudrais tu
m'épouser accus signé les papiers pour
que la ferme soit cédée à andy ne voit
pas de lien direct entre quoi et quoi
entre moi et toi mon cousin respire tôt
la plus belle voiture du mahb il l'a
laissé la ferme un american de temps d
après lui vous vous attendez après quoi
moi j'attends pas pierre fuchs inc
tu devrais venir à new york un jour
anthony ne se mariera jamais s'il faut
attendre encore je continuerai mais ce
faudrait tu te fasses contenu complet si
tu as l'intention d'attendre après lui
veilleux co
menaces et
déjà eu ce que tu poursuivait depuis
l'enfance et que tu n'arrivais pas à
abandonner
tu as mis cette barrière entre nous on
restait sur deux heureuses ou
malheureuses
tu a embrassé adam c'est lui qui m'a
embrassée c'est pour ça qu'il revient
j'ai du mal à comprendre les gens d'ici
vous rendez tout aussi compliqué vous
accepter des choses insensées
je n'aime pas me disputer qui aiment ça
la moitié des landes mais pas moi des
fouilles jour iphone un méchoui franc
peu
le temps j'ai confirmation que l'amour
attention et a été trouvé
durant combien de jours verrons-nous
encore le soleil brille et ne brille pas
il brise moi oui lieu qu'on ainsi qu'aux
[Musique]